Brasil pero no tiene ninguna marca triste.
del accidente provocó diez nuevas líneas
momento 25 por ciento causó bosque
gente enferma en todo el planeta
Hasta la escoria con solo un país.
los estados individuales batieron el récord
macabro sin embargo es que recordar que ayala
población y de cinco intensos en 400
pero genial es eso para los de brasil mientras
el político sí la empresa seagen dvd do
sobre las meditates fafe gere para probar
contener esta pandemia hasta el
control por un lado lo conoces como biólogo
sabir cortinas que se abrieron una
posibilidad espera ahora que pueda ser
masa mortal que las ideas anteriores uv
es decir, el cálculo de skyteam también los poderes de brasil
750.000 muertes lo provocaron y en el mes de
Septiembre la recomendación de la se
experto en asignación de dinero social i
secretos usando la plantilla de forma
preventivo sin embargo el presidente
bolsonaro varese ire la direccion
opuesto como el amplio cielo dicho por
pandemia
propuso recientemente que no es
obligatorio el mas cariglia salva jos
que si vacuna rom o que ya supere
paradas en línea ya que sé que en Brasil bronceado
solo y lomo y porcentaje de
población cubierta por las dos dosis del
la comisión está vacante en este momento
parlamentario que fue responsable de la gestión
de la pandemia y está investigando
tratando activamente de descubrirse a uno mismo existe la
bolsonaro di susa concejal que feria
de forma de semilla permite líneas firmes
para poder contestar la llamada
inmunidad al baño